hello everyone I'm Russia shampoo cell
and joining me today is a jet Cody we
are part of the data science and
engineering team at Netflix and are here
today to talk to you about pattern
matching and scale using finite state
machine one of the areas that our team
works on is around optimizing the signup
flow for someone who wants to subscribe
for Netflix so I'm going to start with
an example from there let's say someone
wants to subscribe to Netflix they were
typically start by landing on the home
page and here we give the user an option
to kick start the signup flow by
clicking on the red button that you see
on the screen now this leads them
through a sequence of steps which
involves selecting a plan registering
for some credentials with which they can
log in later providing us with the
method of payment before they can finish
signing up now this sequence of five
steps is the happy path that a user
could be on to sign up for Netflix with
the least amount of friction but
sometimes we see that the users take a
much longer path to get to the same
point and this might be because they
changed their mind about which plan they
wanted to have or what method of payment
they wanted to use or in some cases even
go back and forth between these options
essentially being stuck in a loop before
they sign up the worst case scenario
occurs when someone abandons the signup
flow Midway so even though our signup
flow is composed of five key steps the
number of actual permutations that might
be occurring out there might be fairly
large a number let's take a different
example this time from somebody who is
already a member at Netflix and let's
say this user decided to play stranger
things now one of the questions that we
might be interested in asking is how did
the user get here did they specifically
search for stranger things and then
decide to play the title or what they
already watching the title and we're
just picking up where they had left off
as you can see the question in this
scenario has smart very differently
and what we are trying to do here is we
are aware of what our destination is and
we are trying to figure out what our
origins were there might be other cases
where we might be aware of what our
origins are and we are trying to figure
out all possible destinations the users
could have gone to so essentially if you
could think of all of these steps of
milestones what we are trying to do is
trace paths across all of these
milestones if that makes sense now let
me walk you through a couple of
challenges that we run into while trying
to do this more often than not our data
is spread over multiple data sources
which are heterogeneous in nature by
virtue of the fact that this data is
being logged by several services out
there the volume can still learn into
terabytes or even finer bytes at times
and we have to sift through all of that
data together a simple insight once
we've answered one question we are
quickly on the path to answer variations
of the same question that we might have
originally started off with and this
analysis tends to get a little
repetitive considering the fact that we
run a really large number of Av tests
all throughout the entire Netflix
product and we are required to do this
analysis over and over again to make
sure the user experience is still
optimal we might also be doing this sort
of analysis to figure out if there are
more opportunities out there to make the
user experience of whole lot better than
it is today
and the number of folks who are asking
this question is not restricted just to
engineers but data scientists analyst
product managers everybody is interested
in these kind of insights so it
certainly doesn't become easy
considering the technical expertise of
all of these users might be pretty
varied if they have to deal with the
prior challenges that I listed before so
let's take a look at a couple of ways in
which we have typically trying to solve
this in the past a common solution that
most people adopt is just collecting up
all of these milestones into memory and
then applying some sort of wildcard
matching on it so for example if you see
that these are the steps that our user
went through we would simply collect
them up into a single string with some
sort of a separator and apply some sort
of wildcard matching on top of it to see
if the path was a match now the syntax
that you see here is from sequel but you
could essentially use while kind of
matching syntax that might be offered by
any language now this is a very
simplistic approach and works well if
your path is really really simple you
don't have any Forks you don't have any
additions you don't have people going
back and forth it works really well in
such cases and it works as long as your
entire path can fit into memory so once
the collapse string should be able to
fit into memory so this works only as
long as all of these assumptions are
true another approach that people might
adopt is using analytical window
functions you could think of window
functions as being some sort of
aggregations being applied on a slice of
data that we care about so going back to
the same example let's say these were
the steps that a user went through and
the question that we were interested in
asking is somebody who landed on a home
page how many of them actually finished
sign up so really the two pieces of
information that we care about our home
page and finish sign up so we can throw
everything else away and just focus on
these two so we filter down
just to these events and then try to
apply some sort of windowing function to
figure out what the preceding and the
following events were so in this case we
would use the functions lead and lag
which are offered by some frameworks to
be able to get to this conclusion this
is a slightly better approach than the
one that I just described but it suffers
through the same problem when your paths
get complex and you start introducing
hydrations or folks or merges so it
doesn't work too well for that option
number three and engineers might relate
to this a little more is organizing your
data in a graph data model with the
vertices representing the milestones
and the edges between these milestones
are the paths now this is a good
approach and it works well except that
you will have to overload your innocency
matrix with a whole lot of additional
information to track loops or how many
times people went back and forth
direction and so on and so forth
again this is an approach probably more
well suited for engineers as I mentioned
and probably less so for the remaining
set of user profiles that I described
before
furthermore we would have to invest in
some sort of frameworks are tools that
are more optimized to handle graph data
models and it's important that these
tools or frameworks play well with our
existing ecosystem of tools so there's
that investment additionally and the
overhead of learning something new so
these kind of challenges sort of goddess
thinking if we could develop some sort
of an easy-to-use solution to work
around all of these challenges but yet
yet to what where we want to go so we
started by listening out all the
requirements of a solution that we will
want to build out primary requirement be
able to express your paths or flows in
curative lis that seems pretty
straightforward we would want to do that
these parts or flows should support
complex alterations so given that even
in a simple signup flow we have seen
users go back and forth imagine all of
the product flows across Netflix we want
to be able to track more complex
hydrations in these videos we already
have a problem where we have to tap into
multiple data sources to get to the
insights that we need so it's imperative
that the solution handles that and it
scales nicely when the volume of data
thrown at it grows ultimately we want to
make it easy for all the users who are
interested in gathering these insights
and so while we are at it why not throw
a bunch of other goodies that make it
easy to use and make it work well with
our existing ecosystem of tools and
frameworks so basically we want to keep
it all simple is the objective in a
nutshell so with all of these
requirements in mind we put together our
work and called it Conneaut now what
point you it does is essentially look
for milestones across a bunch of events
and these events could come from various
data sources and can have different
formats and different structures it
doesn't matter the conduit conduit
really cares about three pieces of
information a timestamp when the event
occurred a name by which it can identify
the event in the pile of data that is
fed to conduit and this is a useful
construct because let's say you had
several sources of truth for the same
piece of information you could designate
or name everything logically as one and
conduit would perceive it as a single
event and look for it and the last piece
of information that we need is a unique
identifier across all of the events now
nobody is if your dataset doesn't have a
unique identifier we could always
generate one on the fly so that's all
the milestones taken care of next
problem we want to be able to measure
all of the paths against some sort of
entity definition and by entities I mean
the slice against which we want to
measure things so with reference to the
examples that I covered before we are
trying to look at paths with reference
to visitors or customers and so these
become our entities now our primary
requirement for the solution was to be
able to express paths intuitively now we
thought about this a little bit and we
even considered an option of writing up
our own DSL and then realized okay
people are not going to use this so it
kind of made sense to look in existing
options that are out there and it struck
us that regular expression notation
works out really really well for this
and if you think about it it supports
all of the constructs that you would
expect to see in a path it supports
quantifiers
it supports direction it supports faults
merges iterations you can get as loose
or as strict as you want with the
notation and so this works out perfectly
so all we would want to do is just
modify the parser to be able to handle
event names instead of single character
tokens that typical parsers would you
out of box for parts for artists box so
regular expressions simplified our first
two requirements that we heard of the
framework now one of the key objectives
are sort of doing this exercise is to
draw some high-level insights as to
where the users are going and you know
where they're spending their time so
it's imperative that the framework
provides ways to easily summarize the
data or at least use use sufficient
number of hooks to gather some summary
insights really really quickly and so
Condor does do that and given the volume
of data that we were dealing with it
kind of became obvious that distributed
processing was the way to go so we
decided to use Apache spark as our
execution engine within which continuity
would run as a framework now we got a
lot of benefits from spark and I would
like to talk about a little bit about
that
so spar scales really really nicely as
your volume of data grows and it's
already part of our ecosystem of dealing
with big data so that worked out great
so we didn't have to throw something new
into the mix the second benefit that you
get a spark is already capable of
reading data from several different
types of data sources so it can read
files it can be tables it can read
elastic search indexes what have you and
given that the spark community is
actively working on introducing new
sources from time to time we would get
all of those benefits for free lastly
our problem of all of these different
data sources being heterogeneous in
nature for soy by the fact that spark
has a really nifty set of api's to make
the transformations happen to move the
data from a heterogeneous format into a
more homogenized structure that can be
fed into conduit so given that spark
solved all of these problems for us
really what we needed to focus on was
just building the framework to handle
the pattern magic so that's what we did
and we decided to use apache spark for
it and it will be going into more
details on how spark works with our
framework to make this happen later on
in the talk ultimately we want to make
sure that this framework is so very easy
to use for anybody who has these kind of
questions and so we offer conduit in two
flavors one is an API which you could
easily integrate and do your existing
workflows that run any sort of ETL and
so it works really well it's built on
top of scala
and our next option is to use a ml
configuration which can be parameterized
very easily so somebody could build out
the configuration once and it could be
used for all of this repetitive use
cases over and over again by simply
changing the parameters so these were
the two ways in which we simplified how
we could make it usable for the users
now with all of that being said I would
like to show a quick demo of how conduit
works and for the demo I'm gonna use a
really simple data set for visitor
navigation just has four pieces of
information you have a timestamp for the
event because we want to make sure that
conduit gets data where timestamps and
we have goods that can uniquely identify
the users we have the country from where
the visitor may have seen a particular
page and we have the actual page itself
so in reality your datasets might be
much more wider than this but we'll just
focus on these four attributes for the
demo and for adding the demo we are
going to be using Jupiter notebooks
which is set up with Apache Ettore and
this is set up using a solace part
kernel which is running spar 2.3 in the
background so let me just switch to the
demo is everybody able to see the font
is it large enough or maker who's bad or
object let's make it bigger so it's
pretty straightforward we just do a
simple setup to get conduit working so
we add a jar and the jar just becomes
available in context and now we could
just use all of the functionality within
conduit I'm just going to run a bunch of
imports and set up some utility methods
so that we can see some neat output that
comes out of the framework so we have
that running and Jupiter is so very easy
to use I think
I'm a big fan of it over the last year
or so okay okay so we're going to start
by just reading in our data and as I
said we're just using spark to read in
the data it already has all of the
options to read different types of data
set we're using a very simple CSV here
so we just want to read in that data and
just to make sure that we read in the
data correctly and we're going to look
at the schema and okay we have the four
fields that I talked about so you're not
much set up and here is what some sample
data might look like so as you can see
we have a good that uniquely defines the
visitor we have a time stamp that's
available for when the event really
occurred the country where it occurred
and the page that was visited so these
are the basic set of inputs that we have
now we'll just annotate this data frame
or what you can think of as a logical
abstraction over the container that
spark uses to hold your data we're going
to annotate this data frame to add the
columns that continuity needs now our
data set already has two out of the
three pieces of information that we want
so we already have a time stamp and we
have something that we could use to
designate as the event so that's already
there this data set does not have a
unique identifier so will generate one
and so we're just going to do that it's
pretty simple now we have the unique
identifier add it in and let's see what
the data looks like with the identifier
added so you have your gourd the
timestamp country event name and your
unique identifier add it in so that's
all we need to get continued going and
now we can start asking a bunch of
questions so let's start with the same
question that I have been going over in
the presentation which is how many
people started on the home page and how
many people finished sign up so it's
really simple we just set up some
metadata where we specify what our path
is and so we have homepage followed by
finish sign are the the way they are
ordered indicates the direction in which
we are looking for the events and the
slash is basically a tote an event name
separator so that a person can identify
where the event
name ends so that's really simple as I
mentioned we have entities against which
conduit measures these paths so we have
the gold available and so we are going
to use the go ahead as you can see this
is a set of strings that it's expecting
which essentially means you could have
several entities based on which you
could evaluate thoughts now by default
conduit would start or sort the data by
the timestamp of the events that it sees
before it runs any sort of processing
but there are other options to add
secondary sorting if you need it
so we set up the metadata that's simple
enough and now I'm going to run the flow
analyser which is going to process this
metadata along with the events that we
have to generate the outputs that we
need so as you can see the analyzer took
in the input and then said okay your
path has two input two events that
really care about so we have the home
page and we have the finished sign up so
I'm going to throw away everything else
that's there in the data and just focus
on these two events so this was a
learning that we took from our second
solution around analytical window
functions so we took a learning from
that and made that into an optimization
for Kanye so imagine if you're
processing billions of rows and really
what you are interested in is maybe 1%
of that data here is how you filter down
to that 1% so it's already doing that
for you and now we just run the analyzer
and it's going to do its thing and tell
us that for users started the flow and
for users finished it so which means for
users started on homepage and for users
finished sign up now this is the summary
inside that we weren't looking to get
but we also have details about how we
got here so this is what the data side
that's processed by continuity looks
like so we have the good that was
processed and we generate what is called
as a flow identifier and so this is
useful in grouping up all of the events
that made up a particular path or flow
and this is particularly beneficial if
even for the same entity they have
multiple instances of a single path
happening so every instance would have
its own version of flow identifier so
you could see a smaller length of the
data
now within the flow events that belong
to the flow identifier we generate
sequence numbers to indicate how the
events were sequenced out before kwon-do
and evaluated them now this is useful if
your time stamps are of different
processions like milliseconds seconds
you somehow normalize it and get it into
conduit but then they are still you know
conflicting with each other so the
sequence number will definitely tell you
this is the order in which the framework
look at it and it's also useful for
other synonyms allocate to that in a bit
we have the event name and the last
piece of information that we add in is
the end of flow indicator now this is
just a boolean indicator which tells us
whether that particular event is the end
of the flow that we were looking at now
this is particularly useful if you had
open-ended flows right so going back to
the scenario I was talking about which
is let's say we know what our origins
are and we don't know what our
destinations are and so this is useful
because now I know what my destinations
are by just filtering down for records
that have this end of flow indicator set
so this becomes super easy when you have
to scan through the data and say oh
these are all the possible destinations
that the users went through getting to
origins is also equally simple we could
just use the sequence number one to
understand where the user started so you
get to the start and the end of any path
pretty easily and it's a sort of
constant time operation so we just do
this and we see all of the paths that
the user went through now let's make a
small tweak in this path and just say we
want to make sure that the user also hit
planned selection so they pick the plan
before the finish sign up and I'm going
to say they did they may have done other
bunch of stuff so we are going to use
the wild-card dot which is again comes
from the regular expression land with a
quantifier of star or asterisk
indicating there may have been zero or
more events that happen between plant
selection and finish sign up so as soon
as I change that expression and
reanalyze the data you see that from for
flows it changes to 3 so out of the four
people you started on the form page and
finish
three of them also visited plant
selection but there was one who didn't
so something was different out there and
this becomes a good pointer for users to
go and look at and figure out what
happened in those cases so as you can
see we can quickly just make simple
changes to just the paths and track all
of these different variations that were
happening so let's get into oh I did
want to mention so because we added the
wild card notation now we can see all of
the events that happened in between
plant selection and finish sign-up so
somebody took eight steps to finish
sign-up starting from homepage as you
can see here if we look at the next
sequence again from homepage but this
time they took six steps so again this
is a good way to tease out okay it's the
number of steps the same every time it's
probably not so something's going on out
there maybe they're going back and forth
between different options so this is
particularly useful to do deep dives
into what's going on out there now let's
say we want to look at events in a
sequence but a whole combination gets
repeated over and over again so people
start on homepage they go to plant
selection and then go back to the
homepage and go to plant selection again
so this sort of back and forth can be
easily represented by just grouping
these two events together in the
parentheses that you see there and then
say the user should have done this sort
of sequence at least once
and this again notation comes from
regular expressions nothing near here so
we just ran through this and now when we
look at it we see that five users
completed the sequence and you'll see
that the first user did this loop twice
so homepage plan selection and then
repeated homepage plan selection again
and same was the case for the next user
but the third one just needed in one
pass so which means something is optimal
out here and people then change their
mind about it which means they got
through the signup flow fairly quickly
so these are some inferences you can
draw from the data
you see now let's say we wanted to get
really crazy with our path expression
and say okay you know forget everybody
else I want to understand who is going
over this loop at least twice right so
we have homepage plan selection this is
our group and we are using again the
quantifier notation from regular
expressions which says they should have
visited the home page plan selection
combination at least twice and then
somehow finish sign up so this is
somebody really really motivated to sign
up so they went through the process
early twice so we've got to look at who
did that one person and so now this one
person is clearly motivated and hence
they went through the signup flow but
somebody else could have just said okay
this is too much for me I'm I'm going to
drop off and that's a lost opportunity
for Netflix and for the customer to have
a lot of joy watching movies and TV
shows what have you so so you know this
is how you could you know get to more
complex insights if you wanted to by
just tweaking so as you can see the
expression is only like a one-liner and
you just make changes and all of the
magic happens now the last example that
I want to cover is around being able to
summarize this data easily and as I
mentioned this is eventually the
insights that we care about like some
sort of summary statistics so now I'm
going to the question that I have in
mind is okay we have home page and we
have finished signup tell me everything
that happened in between and tell me how
many steps does somebody take between
home page and finish seinem and i'm
going to make one more tweak and this is
for users who care about some sort of
conversion rates or you know funnel
entry exit ratios and things like that
we're going to set this particular
parameter which I did not show you guys
before which is set to false by default
saying we are going to allow incomplete
flows which means we are a lot of people
who start the
don't necessarily finish it I'm gonna
set it to true and just run through this
and we're going to see some stats so now
you can see that for people who finish
sign up the most number of steps that
somebody took was eight the least number
was six but for people who abandoned the
signup flow Midway the most number of
steps that they took were nine and the
least number that they took was one so
the one use case you could explain away
maybe they accidentally somehow landed
on the homepage and then they just
abandoned but somebody who went through
nine steps that will be really
frustrating for them to not make it all
the way to finishing sign up and so
these are the use cases that our analyst
or data scientists would try to optimize
for when they are working on the product
so this was a pretty short demo of all
the features that conduit offer it's
actually it offers a lot more I probably
run out of time if I had to go through
everything but hopefully this gives a
taste of what we can really achieve in a
really short period of time now I'd like
to hand it off to a judge who will talk
in detail about how all of this magic
happens under the hood Thank You Rashmi
hello all
I am Ajith Cody and I work in data
science and engineering at Netflix this
is my third time at string loop and I
absolutely love it here
today I plan to dwelve are more into the
architecture and design of continuity
there are plenty of well-known solutions
which can pass a regular expression and
find patterns in a string in a single
process systems but there are few very
few known solutions which can pass a
large volume of data and find patterns
keeping some of these as our guidelines
something
keeping some of these as our guiding
principles we wanted to design a system
which can scale horizontally and match
billions of patterns we want to also
want it to build a system which is easy
to debug and reason about and reason
about and find why a particular pattern
did not match we also wanted to build a
system which is easy to enhance and add
more features we recently added a future
which is to match up or give us the
output of impartial matches if some part
did not fully match but we still want to
see it as the part of the output we
added that feature so we'll soon see how
have you've done this and before that I
wanted to quickly define some of the
building blocks we had one of them is
regular expression regular expression is
a sequence of characters that define a
search pattern for me regular
expressions are wild cards on steroids
then other building block is abstract
syntax tree abstract syntax trees are
data structures that are used to
represent the result of a syntax and
Lissa's abstract syntax trees are also
the central data structures that we use
throughout there also have very less
information of the real syntax compared
to the past free pass tree have dense
information also beautiful the
hierarchical nature of abstract syntax
trees we also refer them as hierarchical
trees the last building block we use is
the finite state machine finite state
machines are abstract machines that has
a finite number of states and
transitions between those states and in
response to external events there's the
state transitions and into in turn
others in into another state this is our
game plan we want to pass the regular
expression for a given path into a
syntax tree as a first step so we use
scholars partial Combinator to parse the
regular expression and construct the
individual expressions of partial
cognate or just a higher-order function
that accepts several passes as inputs
and returns a new parcels as its output
and each parcel
parses the individual
regular expressions we use these
expression types to denote the different
individual expressions event event
represents a token a concat represents
one or con katz is used to join multiple
expressions or a token or is used to
represent Joe to join our R is to
represent match one of the tokens bonded
repeat an unbounded repeat represents
zero or more or occurrences of a token
or an expression we'll soon see how we
use this constructs to build the syntax
tree so we will use one of the examples
which we previously used in our demo
which is homepage followed by plan
selection followed by any event and
followed by finished sign-up finally
looking at just the regular expression
string it's not easy to recognize that
they have a hierarchical nature but
we'll soon see that they have a
hierarchical nature also note that we
can build a rejection engine without
building the syntax tree but will be
very simple to validate regular
expressions by building syntax trees so
as a first step we convert all the
events which are all the milestones
which is the homepage plant selection
and finished sign up as event
expressions and finally we convert any
expression as a repeat expression so
that we can match multiple events and to
build the hierarchical syntax tree we
use the concat expression to join the
multiple join all these expressions and
form a tree note that we can use the
syntax syntax tree we generated to pass
the regular expression but that will
complicate the code instead if you could
lower the abstraction it will be much
similar to build a system which is easy
to debug and reason about and the next
step we will see how we convert the
syntax tree into state machine so that
the evolution becomes easier to build
the finite state machine views the
following States which is the accept
which can consume any event fork which
can split the transition into multiple
transitions a bounded repeat an
unbounded repeat represents one or more
occurrence of a transition a master
unmatched indicate whether a pattern
matched or did not
well soon see how he used this construct
and general construct the finite state
machine finite state machine also
represents a rejects it linearized the
rejects components into graph producing
a format which is a state followed by B
state followed by C state by using this
graph it is very easy to evaluate
against potential events and find a
pattern so the the methodology or the
approach outlined in next slides I was
originally outlined and Ken Thompson's
1968 paper which is regular expression
search algorithm previous search
algorithm used backtracking and
backtracking whenever whenever a pattern
did not match it was very costly because
you have to go back and then that would
mean that you have to do lot of
bookkeeping means said in this paper of
the approach which is outlined was that
we could evaluate multiple states at
once so use some of these approaches and
convert the syntax tree into a state
machine to convert the syntax tree to
state machine the first thing we do do
is we create an except for the homepage
node if we receive an homepage home page
and the accept node will transition into
the plan selection node if it did not
then it will transition to unmatched
node and the pattern matching halts at
this point of time so let's say we
received home page the accept node
matches and will transition to the next
state which is the plan selection the
plan selection let's say if after
homepage we get a plan selection then
the plan selection accept node matches
and a transition to the next state which
is the unbounded repeat state the
unbounded repeat state has a fork that's
one of its end and the fork has two ends
one which is any any events can be
matched and we'll loop it back to the
unbounded repeat and the other end goes
to the finished sign up and the finish
sign up if we'd receive the finish might
sign up it will match and will
transition to the next state which is
the match state as the next step we'll
see how we'll use the state machine to
evaluate events so let's say if we have
this data set which is homepage
followed by plant selection followed by
provide payment and followed by frills
signup and if we pass this if we stream
this data straight to the state machine
then this is how the evaluation would
happen so though as the first step will
pass the homepage to the home page
except node and this would match and
transition to the next state which is
the plan selection node so the next
event we get is the plan selection and
we send it to the accept node of the
plan selection it will match and
transition to the unbounded repeat the
next event we get is provide payment so
the path provide payment we send it to
the unbounded repeat an unbounded repeat
will redirect it to the fork and the
fork will send it simultaneously to the
both ne and the finish signup and in
this case any would match and it will
loop it back to the provide payment so
the last event we get is the finished
signup it has the same trajectory as
before the finished sign up again we
send it to the unbounded repeat and
under bonded repeat redirects it to the
fork and the fork will send it
simultaneously to the booth ne and the
finish signup but in this case it will
match to the finished signup and a
transition to the match State and we
have found a pattern that's matched so
we'll see another scenario let's say
instead of instead of plan selection we
got a login event right and we send it
to the plan selection node in this case
the accept node would not match and it
will transition to the unmatched State
and the pattern matching will halt at
this point of time to scale of pattern
matching horizontally we use Apache
spark Apache spark is a fast and
general-purpose cluster computing system
which distributes the data across the
cluster and paralyze the operations
across on the distributed data set so
looking going back to the example which
is used in this demo where we partition
the data set by good and sorted by the
event time stamp let's say if you have
the billion goods then you will have a
billion partitions and for each billion
partition will create a state machine
note
that not all the billion billion state
machines would be active only only there
will be active as many partitions we are
processing at that point of time so
let's take a deeper look and let's zoom
in how the evaluation happens within the
SPARC node so we send events using the
map partition functionality provided by
the spark which is just just a regular
map object but it loops over a partition
which sends an event to the state
machine and the state machine will send
it by in the sponsor will give you in
the next state so so let's say if the
partition sends an event and we get a
state which is matched and we still have
events to process in that case we create
a new state machine and then evaluate
the rest of the events but it could also
happen that but the stream has ended and
we send a state machine but the state
machine does not respond back with the
match in this case this will mark the
holes flow as unmatched and the pattern
matching halts at that point of time so
as we mentioned before we also do
certain optimizations let's say if you
are if your path was only homepage and
finished sign up and no there's no any
node in between right so since we no
need only homepage and finished sign up
we can do all the filtering upfront so
we only pre only keep those events which
we require which is homepage and finish
sign up and then pass it again to the
SPARC and state machine which will
evaluate and send back the results but
by doing this we can optimize and
improve the performance node but again
if there is any expression in your event
you cannot do this filtering up front so
I've linked out few references and blogs
which we found were particularly useful
during our Delmond of conduit love to
open it for any questions you may have
[Laughter]
so we can take the next question not at
the moment we evaluate them yeah so the
question was do we support matching
multiple patterns simultaneously over a
single pass of the data so originally
that was our plan but then we figured
that the given that the amount of time
that it takes to do even a single pass
is not that high with a significantly
large volume of events we just figured
keeping the API simple to just do one
path at a time made more sense but we
yeah something we might consider in the
future just to add on to improve the
performance what we also do is we cache
the data so we don't have to kind of
rebuild the data set again and then we
can put run multiple expressions at that
point of time so spark offers caching if
for those who are not familiar with and
Netflix we have another special caching
feature which is called materialized
where we once the data gets shuffled
across the various nodes it can just get
stored on the shuffle servers and so it
just reread that same data without
having to reprocess all of the
transformations over over and over again
so that makes it super optimal so even
if you have to make like ten passes over
the data it's for you
[Applause]